olaf scholz macht den großen masken
rückzieher er liegt jetzt im
regierungsflieger jetzt aber mit maske
und das ist der große unterschied zur
vergangenen woche ja da hat uns der
kanzler ja noch erklärt warum er ohne
maske fliegt und wir alle mit maske
fliegen müssen er und sein sprecher
hatten mehrere tage lang erklärt warum
für sie angeblich zu recht andere regeln
gelten als für uns und jetzt wieder
alles anders jetzt gerade fliegt der
kanzler nämlich nach prag zu einem
regierungs besuch in diesen minuten
unter sitzen im regierungsflieger mit
den strengsten masken regeln die es je
gab sozusagen bei uns bildpolitik chef
jan schäfer im studio grüße dich schon
morgen anstatt also dass jetzt alle im
flieger auch wir die maske ablegen
können geht es genau in die andere
richtung oder olaf scholz die maske
wieder auf die strengsten regeln seid ja
seit zwei jahren dort im
regierungsflieger plötzlich ja man kann
den eindruck haben wir sind nicht im
august 20 22 sondern wir befinden uns im
april 2020 also ganz zu beginn der
pandemie als es noch kein impfstoff gab
als überhaupt niemand geimpft als man
gar nicht wusste so richtig wie sich
dieses virus eigentlich verbreitet was
jetzt passiert und was wir sehen ist ja
ein totaler
alleingang den die bundesregierung hier
insgesamt in deutschland ja auch
beschreiben wir sehen einmal genau den
hinweis des regierungssprechers an
unsere kollegen die jetzt mit fliegen
mit olaf scholz nach prag und dort heißt
es dass es einen pcr-test vor abflug
gibt es gab dann nach informationen
unserer kollegen auch noch ein
schnelltest vor abflug und jetzt gibt es
die masken pflicht und warum ist das
eigentlich aus unserer sicht völlig
bekloppt das muss man einfach sagen weil
das virus oder via viel besser geimpft
entgegen dass wir diesen zwei jahre kann
man sagen weiter und fast alle
europäischen länder um deutschland herum
haben im luftverkehr auch keine masken
glück nicht mehr da kann man wenn man
will natürlich macht getragen aber wir
gehen hier einen echten echten anderen
weg quasi der geisterfahrer auf der
autobahn jetzt könnte man ja sagen auch
wenn ich wenigstens hat er dazugelernt
wenigstens merkt er ist kann ja nicht so
sein dass für die politik oder wie viele
es im funk namen für die da oben was
anderes gilt als für den rest der
bevölkerung gleichzeitig fragt man sich
im moment warum gleichen wir uns denn
nicht den freiheiten an sagen wir nicht
alle jetzt haben wir mal auf damit der
winter der kommt noch früh genug es
wurde ja schon lange geschlagen ohne
ende absolut richtig also man hat den
eindruck dass wir keine ampel regierung
mehr haben sondern eine angst regierung
olaf scholz weiß eigentlich ganz genau
war mal finanzminister wie wichtig auch
psychologie ist er hat das selbst
praktiziert als finanzminister in der
korona krise hat ja damals diese
sogenannte bazooka gezogen ein irres
teures milliarden programm um bürger und
firmen in der pandemie zu stützen hat er
extra gemacht um dieses gefühl zu geben
leute wir sind da wir werden diese
pandemie bewältigen was jetzt passiert
ist genau das gegenteil
er sorgt für zusätzliche angst in dem er
auch wieder maske trägt er hat einen
gesundheitsminister der weiterhin massiv
angst verbreitet er vor einem ganz ganz
schlimmen herbst warnt der auch wieder
vor der epidemischen lage waren also das
gegenteil von dem was eigentlich jetzt
auch psychologisch gesehen nötig wäre
ist das was scholz und teile seines
kabinetts aktuell praktizieren dazu
kommt dass seine worte die kanzler worte
und die seines regierungssprechers tanja
wenige tage später nicht mehr gelten die
beiden haben uns vor allen dingen der
region sprecher sehr wortreich erklärt
warum das richtig war nach kanada zu
fliegen mit sonderregeln und jetzt
wenige tage später sind die sonderregeln
abgeschafft auf dem flug nach prag auf
dem kurzen flug und plötzlich gelten die
regeln die für uns alle gelten also was
sagt das über die ja die beständigkeit
von worten der regierung des kanzlers in
diesen zeiten das sagt zumindest dass er
die falschen schlüsse aus der ganzen
debatte um die masken pflicht zieht die
lufthansa hat sich im rahmen dieser
debatte ja vergangene woche auch bei uns
hierbei bild geäußert und eine
vorstellung haben ganz klar gesagt wir
brauchen die masken pflicht im flugzeug
nicht da wird die luft so extrem stark
gereinigt das ist eigentlich wahnsinnig
unwahrscheinlich es sich überhaupt
anzustecken und natürlich kann man
freiwillig mal ausgetragen aber er olaf
scholz und das ist das was ja auch du
gerade bist reagiert auf das auf die
ganze debatte der vergangenen woche mit
dem falschen schluss er sagt nicht wir
haben die masken pflicht für alle auf
nein sie wird ja sogar noch ab oktober
verschärft dann geht nicht nur masken
pflicht sondern pcr masken pflicht an
einen flugzeugen in deutschland
linienfliegern vater fliegern und genau
auf diesem weg befinde er sich auch also
der falsche schluss aus einer sinnvollen
debatte jan schäfer unser politikchef
feld zur masken debatte um den kanzler
eben gerade aber noch mal die bilder auf
dem flug nach kanada gesehen dort alle
ohne maske und jetzt gerade alles wieder
anders
[Musik]